♪♪
(Thunder)
(Wind blows)
(Glass shatters)
(Intense music builds)
Susan:
After we survived Hurricane
Katrina...
Susan:
we thought that we could survive
anything.
(Water rushing)
And we were wrong.
♪♪
Attorney General:
They found 45 dead bodies there.
Now does that make any sense
to you?
♪♪
I'm under a great deal of
pressure to look into what
happened.
Dr. Horace Baltz:
There were 5 days, the most
ungodly conditions.
♪♪
Karen Wynn:
We are getting all of these
patients out of here.
We are nurses,
Karen Wynn:
and we're gonna get it done.
♪♪
As long as we don't get left
behind.
♪♪
Dr. Ewing Cook:
We have to be realistic about
the situation.
♪♪
There is nothing else to do for
them.
Dr. Anna Pou:
Except to make them comfortable.
So what are we talking about?
♪♪
Schafer:
They've asked me to look
into the deaths at Memorial Medical Center.
Schafer:
Anna...
The Attorney Generals Office is
focusing their investigation on you.
They're suggesting that some of
their patients' lives may have
been ended?
I am sure that patients do not
suffer pain.
♪♪
Dr. Bryant King:
Some people who were afraid of
people outside of the hospital.
♪♪
But for me...
Dr. Bryant King:
it was the other way around.
♪♪
Dr. Ewing Cook:
If you were given the choice
between comforting a patient...
Dr. Ewing Cook:
possibly quickening his death,
or...
♪♪
Dr. Ewing Cook:
...abandoning patients to
suffer a slow death.
♪♪
Dr. Ewing Cook:
What would you choose to do?
♪♪
Let me say goodbye, please!
Come on man!
Stay back!
(Sirens)
♪♪
Dr. Anna Pou:
All I did was try to help
people. That is all I did.
♪♪